today on the Matt Walsh show in one of
the worst in justices we've seen in
recent memory the officer who shot
Rashard Brooks in self-defense is being
charged with murder we'll talk about
this case and and why the charges are
just completely insane also related to
this the media is attempting to make a
saint a hero posthumously out of Rashard
Brooks and and we know that this is what
they do this is a tactic so I want to
discuss the actual truth about this man
what sort of man was he I think I think
that's important we'll talk about that
also five headlines and in our daily
cancellation in honor of my birthday
which is today no big deal don't make a
big deal out of it I will be cancelling
cake just hear me out on this I have a I
have I have I will make my case and you
need to hear it because this is
important and these are the kinds of
things we talk about on the show the
important things all of that coming up
but first a word from LifeLock you know
having your identity stolen is I think a
hassle will be putting it mildly it's a
very very troubling thing to go through
very difficult thing to resolve while
many people continue to work from home
on computers and devices we have an
alert about large-scale phishing
campaigns that are undergoing Microsoft
is warning that phishing emails which
appear to be coming from the Johns
Hopkins Center are trying to trick
people to open an attachment disguised
as a cover 19 report and then that
downloads a file that gives hackers
access to their PCs so this these
attacks come in many different ways you
never know exactly what to expect
fortunately life lock is always one step
ahead of the game life lock detects a
wide range of identity thefts like your
social security number being for sale on
the dark web that's something you'd like
to know about if they detect your
information has potentially been
compromised they will send you an alert
and you will know right away and you
also have access to a dedicated
restoration specialist who will handle
to handle your case and if you become a
victim then you're gonna have that that
tool at your disposal as well nobody can
prevent all identity theft or monitor
all transactions at all businesses life
lock can see threats that you might miss
on your own join now and save up to 25
percent off your first year go to life
lock calm slash walls that's life lock
dot-com slash walls for 25% off
Fulton County District Attorney Paul
Howard in Atlanta who is by the way
under investigation for funneling funds
from a nonprofit to supplement his
salary and who has been repeatedly
accused of sexual harassment by a
subordinate and who was now facing a
primary challenge decided to charge the
cop who shot Rashard Brooks insult in
self-defense with felony murder the
other officer on the scene has also been
charged now to review to review the race
chart Brooks case Brooks is the
convicted violent felon who passed out
drunk behind the wheel of his car in a
Wendy's drive-through they called the
police because he was blocking traffic
because he was passed out drunk in his
car police came to talk to him talk to
him for a while gave us a Bridey test he
failed
so they tried to make an arrest Brooks
assaults the officers steals their taser
fires it at them multiple times and then
on the second attempt to fire it at them
they shot and killed him all of this as
any rational person can see is entirely
the fault of Rashard Brooks every step
of the way everything that happened
Rashard Brooks is Fault in fact let's
take a look at that video again of the
shooting and the lead up to it if you
haven't seen it yet this is important
context so take a look at this auto mr.
Brooks will you take it for layer of
breath test for me yes or no
I don't want to refuse anything I think
yes or no it's completely up to you okay
just wait here while I go I mean what
kind of drinks did you I'm not sure
there's some Chi orders she said top
shelf or whatever
top shelf one I'm not sure it was like I
said her birthday and he had about one
and a half drinks she don't remember
what kind of drinks they won no sir all
right I really don't before all right I
think you've had too much to drink to be
drivers put your hands on your back for
me
alright that officer that you saw there
trying to be very reasonable is facing
felony murder for shooting a violent
criminal who was attacking him remember
you could see in the video we're told
that he was shot in the back maybe he
was irrelevant because he was turning
around and pointing up pointing a weapon
at the officers after he'd already
assaulted them after he'd already made
it clear that he would do anything he
was going to do anything he would resort
to anything to escape so he made it very
very clear he made it extremely clear
that he was a lethal threat to them and
now he's pointing a weapon at them in
fact a weapon that is categorized as a
deadly weapon by by by the state of
Georgia we'll get to that in a second
and so they shoot him now many reports
surfaced last night saying that hundreds
of Atlanta Atlanta cops were walking off
the job in protest of this unjust
prosecution refusing to answer calls you
know go basically going on strike good
for them this is exactly what needs to
happen and this should be happening
across Atlanta it should be having
across the country this is what cops
need to do widespread strikes if you
know if if if the people want mayhem if
they want Anarchy if they don't want
cops there to protect them then they can
have it now before we go any further I
want to talk about and we'll talk about
all this in more detail but let's take a
look at a few of the clips from the
press conference that the DA Howard gave
yesterday where he was explaining his
reasoning for filing these charges
because you have to see this for
yourself if you haven't seen it it's a
really incredible press conference in a
lot of ways in all bad ways you have to
see and hear as this guy tries to
justify his decision to throw an
innocent man to the wolves
he he's very desperate to justify it but
his reasoning is tortured to say the
least
so watch so in reaching our decision
there were some considerations that we
considered important and one of the
things that we noted from our evaluation
was that mr. Brooks on the night of this
incident was calm he was cordial and
really displayed a cooperative nature
secondly even though mr. Brooks was
slightly impaired his demeanor during
this incident was almost jovial also we
noted that he received many instructions
from the Atlanta officers and he was
asked many questions some of the
questions he was asked repeatedly but
for 41 minutes and 17 seconds
he followed every instruction he
answered the questions
yeaji catch that Brooks was Brooks the
violent criminal who was assaulting
officer stole a weapon was shooting it
at them was calm cordial cooperative and
jovial this is what passes for calm
cooperative cordial and jovial
apparently apparently you can cordially
assault a police officer now be honest I
haven't specifically looked up any of
these words in the dictionary but I'm
pretty sure that assaulting a police
officer is not going to fall under the
definition for any of these words
although that might change I mean we
know that the Webster's dictionary
changed the definition of racism because
BLM activists told them to so maybe
they'll maybe we're gonna get a change
to the definition of cordial because BLM
demands it and it gets worse if you can
believe it listen we concluded and
considered it as one of our important
considerations that mr. Brooks never
presented himself as a threat
at the very beginning he was peacefully
sleeping in his car after he was
awakened by the officer he was
cooperative and he was directed to move
his car to another location he calmly
moved his car mr. Brooks was asked
whether or not he had a weapon he
indicated that he did not without any
resistance he passed his driver's
license to the officers and the officers
then asked mr. Brooks whether or not he
would consent to a pat-down us a body
search and mr. Brooks allowed them to
search him and the search yielded no
weapon we found that it was of interest
that when the officers patted mr. Brooks
down they noticed there was a bulge in
his pants they did not pull that item
out of his pocket they took mr. Brooks
word that that bulge represented a
number of dollar bills but mr. Brooks
never displayed any aggressive behavior
behavior during the seventy forty one
minutes and 17 seconds never presented
himself as a threat peacefully sleeping
in his car peacefully sleeping that's
one hell of a way for a DA to describe a
guy passed out drunk behind the wheel he
blew over a point one the limit is 0.08
/ 0.1 for a man of his size you know
you'd have to drink five or six drinks
in an hour to get to that point which
many people are capable of drinking that
much but the point is if you drink that
much and then you drive and you're
peacefully sleeping in the car that's
not sleeping that's passed out that's
what we call passed out drunk
I wonder kook could I go pass out drunk
on the DA's porch could I go to his
house on his porch sprawl out maybe
bring a blanket can i peacefully sleep
on his porch after a night of drinking
and you know he's not gonna call the
cops right what
he refrained from calling the cops
because he doesn't want to disturb my
hallowed slumbers now and he keeps God
in both of those clips you hear that he
goes back time and again he's hammering
on this 41 minutes and 17 seconds thing
he keeps saying that for 41 minutes and
17 seconds Brooks was this just a swell
guy he's a great guy peaceful 441
minutes and 17 seconds 41 minutes and 17
seconds yeah for 41 minutes and 17
seconds unfortunately at 41 minutes and
18 seconds
he became a violent sociopath attacking
and assaulting cops and stealing their
weapon and using it against them that's
what happened at 41 minutes and 18
seconds but but from zero seconds to 41
minutes and 18 seconds you know he was
nice what so what what what are you
saying exact are you saying that he had
been you know once you get to 41 minutes
and 18 seconds you're allowed to do
whatever you want as long as you're nice
to the cops and cooperative for 41
minutes and 17 seconds then you're fine
once you get to 40 minutes and 18
seconds then the purge is on and you
could do whatever you want is that what
you're saying if that's not what you're
saying then who gives a damn that he was
he was he was a nice guy for 41 minutes
Oh 41 minutes of being a nice guy you
mean he didn't attack or try to kill
anybody for 41 minutes wow that's
impressive
let's give him a medal pots given the
Medal of Honor posthumously medal of
freedom all the medals Nobel Peace Prize
let's give ray char Brooks the Nobel
Peace Prize because for 41 minutes he
refrained from trying to kill police
officers yeah I mean I mean after that
he started he tried to kill him but for
41 minutes my goodness what I this this
man is a hero now it's interesting that
this guy Howard says the officers lives
were not in danger you know Brooks only
had a Taser that's interesting because
here's what Howard himself only a couple
of weeks ago said about tasers when he
was charging police officers with
assault for using a Taser on protesters
here's what he said about tasers then
charged with aggravated assault of ms
pilgrim and this is for pointing a Taser
Etna Cesare pilgrim and as many of you
all know on the Georgia law a Taser is
considered as a deadly weapon under
Georgia law a deadly weapon under
Georgia law according to Howard's own
words
Brooks was using a deadly weapon against
the officers and yet they're being
charged with murder for responding with
deadly force when he is using deadly
force against them the standard here
seems to be according to this crooked
prosecutor that tasers are only deadly
weapons when cops use them if you use
them against the cop it's not a deadly
weapon anymore this again is total
lunacy it is madness is one of the worst
and justices I've ever seen and I don't
say that as hyperbole it really is
I'm glad the officers are walking off
the job I hope they do it like I said in
cities across America
if people want anarchy let them have if
they want their cities run by violent
criminals and sociopaths like Rashard
Brooks good
have at it enjoy well let's be honest
about this for once let's be clear about
what's happening ok officer Rolf is
being charged because of his race his
crime is being a white cop that's his
crime that's that's that's the the great
crime that he committed is being a white
cop if this was a black cop and a white
suspect no charges are going to be filed
we all know that there's no question
this
racial retribution the DEA is a bigot
and a racist targeting a man for his
race he should be disbarred and he
should go to jail now I ask again how
are cops supposed to do their jobs like
this really how are they supposed to do
it they're out here every night dealing
with the worst people humanity has to
offer that's most of what a cop is does
is going to be that I think I mentioned
before you know I remember I got a
speeding ticket this is years ago I've
gotten several speeding tickets afraid
to say but this particular one was was
years ago and and you know I was going
well over the speed limit so I deserved
it but I was I was at the court and I
was talking to the cop before we went in
to you know talk to the judge
and he was saying to me that you know he
really doesn't like that the the only
time he that he one of the only times on
his job that he that he deals with just
sort of nice law-abiding normal people
is what he's giving him speeding tickets
because the rest of the time you know
he's answering domestic violence calls
he's just in he's in areas where there
are a lot of crime he's dealing with
criminals and one of the only times that
he's actually just dealing with a you
know decent peoples because he's given
one speeding ticket and he doesn't you
know it's it's kind of that kind of
wears on you after a while
I remember the cop saying that and in
you know that always that has always
stood out to me because of that that's
kind of true most of the time cops
they're dealing with dangerous that
they're cops they're gonna be dealing
with dangerous people criminals they are
doing a lot of domestic violence stuff
you know that's that's gonna be a lot of
the calls they're responding to and or
you know things like this someone passed
out drunk dealing with that drug addicts
and so on and so forth so they're out
trying to enforce the law on people who
like Brooks think nothing of lashing out
violently sometimes fatally they're
dealing with sociopaths a lot of the
time
this is what they're up against and now
if they have to defend themselves in a
situation like that they know they'll go
to jail so they're in a position where
they're dealing with a violent dangerous
person and a bad person as Brooks was
and he has decided to turn it violent
and immediately now the cops know
they're in a position where this can go
a few ways they can be killed or they
can protect themselves and kill
potentially and then face the very real
possibility that they're gonna go to
prison for the rest of their lives and
be reviled across the world as racists
and there's gonna be riots and they're
their family's gonna have to go into
government protection for the rest of
their lives I mean they know that how do
you do your job under those
circumstances important because we've
seen this process play out many times
already the game the tactic from the
left whenever there's a shooting like
this is to turn the criminal into a
martyr into a saint into a man of
unimpeachable character a pillar of his
community a loving father and husband
etc etc etc this is not just about not
speaking ill of the dead it's not just
that they they don't want to speak ill
of the dead this is way beyond that
because they are just not speaking ill
they're canonizing sanctifying making
heroes out of them the point is
obviously emotional manipulation make it
so that rational discussion is
impossible disallowed make it so that
the only thing you're allowed to say
about the death of the man is that it's
an unspeakable tragedy and the world is
so much worse now than its that he's
gone and it's the worst thing of the
world and you've been even crying
yourself to sleep five nights in a row
over it make it so that that's that's
the only thing you're allowed to say
that's the only acceptable take on this
matter because then it's impossible to
argue that he was the aggressor that it
was his fault
it's impossible to and even if even if
it wasn't as funny even if he wasn't the
aggressor it's still gonna
impossible to inject any kind of nuance
into the conversation at all and we've
seen this happen many times it started
with Michael Brown Michael Brown was a
violent sociopath who assaulted a store
clerk for no reason
stole something just for the sake of
stealing of this distort Clarke tried to
stop him grabbed him by the neck and
shoved him walks down the street then
tries to kill a cop it's just a bad
violent person is a terrible person and
they made him into a gentle giant you
know they they they that was the phrase
we kept hearing there's a gentle gentle
gentle man young man and we get his
graduation picture over and over again
we see it now Rashard Brooks ABC News
has this headline
Rashard Brooks remembered for hard work
and dedication to family hard work and
a Shinto family will get back to that in
a second what what yeah in what way was
he dedicated to his family I'm wondering
looking back to that here's the mayor of
Atlanta on CNN describing Brooks as a
guy you're rooting for this has been
hard and it is really been difficult for
me to put aside my own anger and sadness
during this time and really be able to
articulate what our communities need to
hear because the reality is what can you
say I've watched the body cam video I
watched it for 30 minutes
I watched the interaction with mr.
Brooks and it broke my heart when he
talked about his daughter's birthday
party that he was planning for this is
not confrontational this was a guy that
you were rooting for and even knowing
the end watching it you're going just
let him go just let them go let them
call somebody to pick them up by the way
mayor no you don't let a convicted
violent felon who's passed out drunk
behind the wheel go you don't just let
him go and that's not what normal people
are thinking when they see that I'll
just let him go
you don't let him walk away you don't
call them an uber the cops are not a
concierge service for drunk felons
that's not what they do
you idiot and you know there's there's
you don't let the the the drunk felon
just go you enforce the law why is he
special if I passed out drunk behind the
wheel I would expect to get arrested
many people have been arrested for that
kind of thing thousands of people across
the country have been arrested for for
driving drunk and most of them were
still awake at least when they got
pulled over why the hell is there any
particular reason why Ray chard Brooks
should have been special and let go when
nobody else would be in that
circumstance and and then
we also hear that once all this happened
and he's running away they just let him
go
they they didn't have to shoot him never
mind the fact that he's pointing
somethings pointing a weapon at them but
even if he wasn't you know something
even if he wasn't pointing which he was
but even if he wasn't you have again a
drunk violent dangerous felon who has
already demonstrated that he will do
anything to get away uh he doesn't care
and he'll he'll resort to violence
doesn't matter to him you're gonna just
let him run off into the night and and
what hope that he goes home and sleeps
it off and waits for the cops to come
pick him up the next day is that what
you're gonna do is that the safest thing
for the community and no Brooks is not a
guy that you're rooting for I'm not
rooting for him I wouldn't root for him
here's CNN again this is Anderson Cooper
saying that Brooks is trying hard to do
right by his family and he's reaching
heroically for redemption given the news
tonight that one fired Atlanta police
officer has been charged with a capital
crime another also faces serious charges
and the killing of Rashard Brooks the
next item is haunting you'll see what
might have been a story of struggle and
perhaps redemption in video obtained
exclusively by CNN's Van Jones mr.
Brooks talks about life after
incarceration and the impact it's had on
his family the hamp family that he's
trying hard to do right by trying for
redemption which he can see within reach
in which he can not know will never come
and on and on and on you get the idea
okay so let's talk about the reality and
the reality is this that because the
truth matters reality matters truth
matters here this race char Brooks was a
bad man a violent man an abuser of women
and children Brooks in 2014 pleaded
guilty to false imprisonment family
violence battery and felony cruelty
against children now if you're wondering
how you get a felony cruelty to children
charged in Georgia
let me just read from a lawyer website
its Conway and Strickler might you know
just google it is what popped up of
describing the parameters of the cruelty
to children crimes
says this is not specifically related to
race our Brooks but this is the charge
that he was he pled guilty to willfully
depriving a child of his or her basic
needs for survival to the point that
health and well-being are jeopardized or
causing a child cruel or excessive
mental or physical pain our considered
first-degree Cruelty to Children
offenses criminal negligence that causes
crooler excessive mental or physical
pain falls under the heading of second
degree cruelty to children while the
offense of cruelty to children in the
third degree can result when an
individual intentionally allows a child
to witness forcible felonies battery or
family violence so that's a ratio Brooks
falls in somewhere that's just one of
his crimes dedicated to his family
felony cruelty to children dedicated to
his family a family man and we're told
he he wanted to get home for his his
daughter's birthday so he's out passed
out drunk in the middle of the night
that's what you do when you want to get
home and see your child for it for her
birthday I mean I relate to you know
wanting to be there for your child's
birthday I got four kids I want to be
there for the birthdays I want to be
there you know for as long as I can
through their lives that's why I'm not
gonna drive pass out drunk you know in
the middle of the night or at any other
time of day and that's why if I did do
that and I was getting arrested I
wouldn't start assaulting the cops and
throw my life away it's not what you do
that is not what you do if you want to
see your kids
drunk driving resisting arrest assault
of a police officer assault with a
deadly weapon those are the crimes we
can add to the crimes he already
committed so we got everything I listed
Plus drunk driving resisting arrest
assaulting a police officer assault with
a deadly weapon on top of cruelty to
children false imprisonment family
violence domestic abuse no this is not a
man dedicated to his family this is not
a man that you root for
I don't root for child abusers I don't
know about you mayor
I don't root for child abusers they're
not the people that I root for it
I don't root for violent sociopaths who
use deadly weapons against police those
aren't the people that I root for
I don't root for men like that no he was
not a good man he was not trying to turn
his life around
don't give me that you don't drive drunk
pass out a drive-through lathe and
assault cops if you want to turn your
life around trying hard he's trying hard
to get to get back on there I mean I've
never done any of those things and it
required no effort at all not to do it
I've been pulled over as I said I've
been pulled over many times I've never
assaulted a police officer it required
no effort at all for me to refrain from
assaulting the police officer so you're
telling me that that he's trying hard
and can't manage to stop himself from
assaulting an officer with a deadly
weapon in that case he's worse than I
thought because if that was the absolute
best he could do if that was him at his
best that's him trying hard well I'd
hate to see him at his worst and it
sounds like his children did see him at
his worst and paid the price for it
so don't give me this BS I don't want to
hear it we can't allow this to happen
this time
we can't let them turn Rashard Brooks
into a hero as saying anything like that
this is a bad man a violent felon that
needs to be the message because it's the
damn truth and it's what we need to say
it matters you
can't get squeamish about it and say I
don't want to you know he's a man passed
away I don't want to okay well you could
be squeamish and you could be nice about
it and they're gonna build this
narrative and they're gonna use that
narrative to send an innocent man to
jail forever if not the death penalty
that's the narrative they're gonna use
so you could be a very nice person and
not want to contradict that narrative
then you could very nicely sit there
while a man is sent effectively or
literally to his death let's go to news
all right number one a couple of weeks
ago it was claimed that a truck driver
made a white power sign at a black lives
matter protest as he was driving by the
mob went into action
of course the man was fired well now
he's speaking out this this guy that
supposedly did a white power sign at a
black lives matter protest explaining
that he never made a white power sign he
was cracking his knuckles as he drove by
and there are other details as well
about this guy that I think are relevant
so watch this local news report on it
it's scary that you can be charged tried
and convicted on social media without
your permission with no corroborating
evidence of any type a local SD G&E
worker has been fired after allegations
of racism were made against him now he's
speaking exclusively to NBC 7 about what
he calls a major misunderstanding he
says his employer jumped to conclusions
and he should not have lost his job
preassure ether has the story
it all started about two weeks ago near
a black lives matter rally in Poway
Emmanuel Cafferty says he had an
interaction with a member of the public
that later got posted on Twitter
he says shortly after he was fired by
his employer SD G&E this was the tweet
that Emmanuel Cafferty says started it
all it shows an SD G&E worker making a
hand gesture that some say is a white
supremacist sign when my supervisor said
that I was being accused of doing a
white supremecy ester that was baffling
Cafferty is the man in the picture and
says he had no idea what the symbol men
he was just crafting his knuckles but
shortly after he was informed that he
was suspended by SDG any pending an
investigation and a few days later he
was fired I do that a lot when I'm
driving it has no racist intent behind
it and I was confident that I would be
able to you know with my character show
SD Genie that I'm not a racist according
to the anti-defamation league this hand
sign has been used in recent years by
white supremacists as a white power
gesture but a post on the organization's
website says that it is also widely used
as a sign signifying approval and
therefore shouldn't be assumed to be a
white supremacy symbol unless there's
other evidence to support those claims I
don't know how long it's gonna take me
to get over this wait to lose your dream
job for playing with your fingers that's
a hard pill to swallow okay so that this
is and you know we have to appreciate
the anti-defamation league explaining to
us what the okay sign means in this how
many times we have to go through this
the okay sign is not a white power sign
and never was that was an Internet hoax
I think those 4chan made that up and
they're still going with it
oh but they at least they'll admit that
see sometimes people can do that and not
mean anything by it
sometimes but you know it could be that
they're white supremacist so this was a
completely innocent man speaking of
innocent man being being accused of
things this that's sort of the theme
here just a normal guy just a guy doing
his job
now he's unemployed he's reviled as a
racist because someone caught him making
an offensive shape with his fingers
meanwhile he's not even white you saw
the guy right he's Mexican this is a
mexican-american okay man of mad
kenderson
he's fired from his job for being a
white supremacist and he's Mexican how
did that conversation go when his
cowardly employers pulled him in and
said yes sorry we have to let you go for
for being a white supremacist yeah but
I'm not white though I'm not yes but
you're suspected white supremacist I'm
not you see not whites this here I
literally cannot be a white supremacist
it's impossible it is actually
impossible I am NOT white you see
everything going on here non whiteness I
imagine the covers I hope the
conversation went something like that
anyway this is yeah it's it's collective
insanity we've fallen into collective
hysteria hey you know it's it's you
can't reason your way out of it anymore
if we're firing a guy because he was
cracking his knuckles in a Finn
offensive way and saying that it makes
him a suspected white supremacist even
though he's Mexican yeah okay well where
do you go from there you can't argue
against that it's not like someone who
would defend that you you can't present
an argument to them that's gonna change
their mind this is someone in order to
argue against someone in order to
present an argument someone they have to
they have to have a functioning brain
that they're willing to use and
unfortunately there are a lot of people
in our country that don't have
functioning brains or at least are not
willing to use them if they do and so
there's nothing you could say to them
number two here's an attack that
happened outside of a gas station in
Texas take a look the victim says the
assailant screamed black lives matter so
this is basically justice Millette
except races reversed and it actually
happened so I guess it's nothing like
Jesse some what come to think of it but
it's its you in terms of how think about
how gratuitous that attack what that
just the attack the justice Millette
claimed happened completely gratuitous
and ridiculous that's one of the ways
you knew it was fake
except here that sort of thing actually
happened we know it had because we can
see it only the races are reversed and
of course we know that you reverse the
race is back and this is a you know
reason white guys doing this who are the
culprits then that's national news its
headlines there's probably gonna be
protests and riots so on and so forth
number three a report from The Daily
wire says infectious disease expert dr.
Anthony Fauci a key member of the
president Donald Trump's a president
Amish aren't Sakura virus task force
admitted Tuesday that health experts
including himself downplayed the
efficacy of face masks in preventing the
spread of coma nineteen out of concern
that Americans would snap up the
available stock and there would be none
left for health care workers so he's
just the latest person to admit this and
I guess most people are okay with it it
seems like from the reaction they're
admitting that they lied to the public
and by their own logic put the public in
danger from those lies because they
thought that we couldn't handle the
truth how is that not an enormous
scandal number four
john bolton has a book out where he
talks about some of the stuff some of
the stuff i don't care i don't care
about this this is what i just don't
care I really don't I'm done with all
this now all the drama with Trump and
the personal feuds on both sides I just
don't care yeah I mean I get it okay we
know who Trump is I'm not surprised just
I get we get it now I I personally for
one I get it
I don't need another book and John
Bolton some of the stuff he's accusing
Trump of I really don't care at all to
be honest with you but some of the stuff
is
using Trump of sounded you know if they
actually happen sound like they'd be
potentially criminal huge scandals what
why didn't you say something when they
happened if they actually did
why didn't you testify why didn't you
say something you wait you waited till
you're fired and they waited wait
another what year to put it in a book so
you can sell a book off of it so if it
did actually happen then that just makes
you a horrible scumbag as well one of
the things he claims is that Trump
endorsed concentration camps and in
China I don't know if they happen or not
that wouldn't be a crime on Trump's bar
but it would be a big scandal that's the
cut if that actually happened and you're
a man of integrity you you would come
out right away and say something about
it while you're still in the
administration right because then you
have some credibility then it's then
it's not like you're a spurned or
employee or you know a jilted but it's
it's not like that you're not you're not
a disgruntled ex-employee but no instead
he he writes in his little notebook
supposedly and then brings it up a year
later so he could sell books of it and
it's just and then Trump is on Hannity
last night and he's and he's tweeting
and he's talking about John Bolton no
one cares about this this is not what's
important we don't care
personal feuds mr. president we care
about the fact that the country is
falling apart at the seams that's what
matters that should be your focus 100%
of your focus entirely nothing else
number five finally variety has an
article making the rounds the headline
ten problematic films that could use
warning labels so this is we know about
Gone with the Wind
problematic film that now has a warning
label on HBO max variety helpfully has
suggested other films that should use
that should have warning labels they
have what do they say they say Dirty
Harry should have a warning Forrest Gump
says Forrest Gump was made by
intelligent people won six Oscars and is
beloved by many while the film is
condescending to anyone with a
disability Vietnam vets and people with
AIDS among others it's actually hostile
to prop two protesters activists and
counterculture as a bonus lovable title
character Nathan Bedford Forrest was
named after his grandfather the first
Grand Wizard of the Ku Klux Klan so
that's very problematic Indiana Jones
and the Temple of Doom is problematic
needs a warning label Steven Spielberg
and George Lucas are generally
compassionate filmmakers but this film
went a little too far in trying to
replicate the mood of 1930s action
serials like those old movies the exotic
villains are portrayed as primitive and
bloodthirsty foreigners resulting in
negative and stereotypical depictions of
India and of Hindu customs and then okay
all right
speaking of things
cares about how about this if you're the
sort of person who would get offended by
Indiana Jones in the Temple of Doom or
Forrest Gump if you're the sort of
person who would need a warning label on
a film rather than us putting warning
labels in all the films why don't you
just deport yourself to Jupiter and
leave the planet and never come back I
think that would be the best for all
parties concerned now we're gonna go to
our daily cancellation it's a very
important one before we do if you're not
already a daily water member you should
consider getting a reader's past at
daily wire.com it's great value only
three dollars a month and when you sign
up you get the first month for only 99
cents you also get access to our mobile
app articles ad free and access to
exclusive editorials all for again just
99 cents for the first month so if you
haven't checked out the readers past
already go through daily wired.com
and sign up for just a buck and it
really is that easy and I would highly
recommend it now for our daily
cancellation today on my birthday I
thought it was a perfect occasion to
cancel cake now I want to explain why
and this is by far the most important
issue I'm gonna talk about today on the
show so you need to pay attention you
know the other day I was talking to my
wife and she said that she wanted to get
me a cake for my birthday and this is
exactly the kind of microaggression that
people around the world have been
suffering for too long every birthday is
made to revolve around cake it's just
assumed that if you have a celebratory
occasion birthday wedding retirement
whatever it is there's gonna be a cake
there should be a cake what kind of cake
do you want it's not even like do you
want a cake it's what kind of cake isn't
gonna be there's the assumption of the
cake the pro cake assumption is itself
deeply problematic meanwhile cake sits
there confidently arrogantly on its on
its lofty perch as humanity's
celebratory pastry of choice when in
fact it is subpar okay
sometimes outright bad most of the time
acceptable but not special it's kind of
like the I don't know the the Alex Smith
of pastries so let's be honest in this
this is what you can't deny this you
have never had a great piece of cake in
your life you never have don't tell me
that you have I know I know better than
you do about what about what's happened
in your life and what you've what you've
eaten okay so let me tell you you have
never had a great piece of cake maybe
you've had pieces of cake that were
great for cake by the standards of cake
they were great you've never had cake
that was truly great that was that was
that truly deserve to be in the pantheon
of your all-time great dessert
experiences if you were to make a list
of the ten BET best desserts you've ever
had nobody's birthday cake is gonna be
on the list unless you're mentally
disordered now so here's the thing
you've had slices of pie that warranted
those accolades you've had brownies that
did you've even had cookies that did you
maybe have had ice cream that did and
yet those don't get the recognition that
cake gets and if somebody on his
birthday say me for example wants to
have brownies instead of cake he sneered
at mocked discriminated against
belittled assaulted killed I've seen it
happen I've seen someone be murdered on
their birthday for not having cake
happens all the time
okay and I'm done with this so it's time
to be honest it's time to confront the
truth cake is okay not special not
sufficient for birthday celebrations
what does it tell you here's all the
proof you need all the evidence you need
what does it tell you that the actual
cake part of the cake has to be
slathered in sugary disgusting icing
nobody has a cake without icing why is
that I mean
cake the actual cake is the cake the
icing is just uh is just an added
supposed to be an added bonus icing on
the cake they say right that's where the
but nobody's just gonna have the cake
why is because the cake is not that
great cake has been skating by for far
too long like this and I've had enough I
don't want to hear excuses like well
cake can be decorated you can put
candles on cake those are aesthetic
factors I'm talking about taste I'm
talking about what the food actually
tastes like I mean I can put a canned I
can put a candle on my desk does I mean
I'm gonna eat my desk in fact you know
there's so many so many the cakes I've
had or so stale that I might as well be
eating a desk and that's the other
problem that in order for a cake to be
even just passively good the person
making it needs to be an expert chef
most people don't know how to me and and
even then expert chef the best you could
hope for is a b-minus c-plus type again
most people their cakes are you know D's
and F's because you have to be an expert
to really make a good cake most attempts
of making homemade cakes end up
disastrously most store-bought cakes are
terrible so I don't know how many times
I've been at someone's birthday party
they serve me a cake I take one bite I
throw it directly at their head and say
what the hell is this get this out of my
face
what are you doing giving me this go to
hell you scumbag it's a whole scene you
know
cops are called everything this could be
avoided if we did birthday pie birthday
chocolate chip cookies birthday brownies
even a birthday doughnut would be better
as long as it's not
Dunkin Donuts which is also canceled for
being revolting uh and there we go
that's my that's why cake is cancelled
I'm glad we could finally have this
much-needed discussion and of course in
conclusion
happy birthday to myself I'll talk to
you guys tomorrow
Godspeed the Matt Walsh show is produced
by Sean Hampton executive producer
Jeremy boring our supervising producers
are Mathis Glover and Robert Sterling
our technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Dani D'Amico and our audio is
mixed by Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 if you prefer
facts over feelings aren't offended by
the brutal truth and you can still laugh
at the insanity filling our national
news cycle well tune in to the Ben
Shapiro show we will get a whole lot of
that and much more see you there